ja es zeigt doch mal wieder wie
heuchlerisch eigentlich die EU ist und
es wird eine bargeldobergrenze von
10.000 € klar gemacht und selber haben
die 600.000 € zu Hause in Plastiksäcken
rumlegen aber erste Frage natürlich
erste Punkt was hat denn die FIFA mit
der EU gemeinsam erstens sie sind
korrupt und zweitens haben sich von
Katar schmieren lassen ja Eva Kiwi
vizekommissionspräsidentin der EU hat
Geld angenommen von Katar um Werbung für
den Wüsten statt zu machen und hat damit
den größten korruptionskandal in der
Geschichte der EU ausgelöst nur einer
von vielen die EU ist er seit jeher
eigentlich immer wieder bekannt durch
Skandale durch Korruption und wir wissen
ja der Fisch stinkt immer vom Kopf denn
ich bin mir sicher unter ihr aber auch
über ihr gibt's doch das ein oder andere
aufzuarbeiten schau mal über sie da ist
nämlich die Ursula von der Leyen ja wir
kennen sie noch als ehemalige deutsche
bundesverteidigungsministerin die dann
wegen der berateraffäre ähm aus der
Achtung Wortwitz Schusslinie gebracht
werden musste und entsorgt wurde
Richtung Größe und jetzt auch eine kurze
Frage an das verehrte Publikum wer hat
denn Ursula von der Leyen als
kommissionspräsidentin gewählt genau
richtig niemand von uns war gewählt
wurde eigentlich Manfred Weber der CSU
aber da man sieht da man sie entsorgen
musste hat man sie eingesetzt und es
zeigt wieder mal das
Demokratieverständnis der EU es ist und
bleibt eine fassadendemokratie und
Ursula von der Leyen ist das sehr
geschickt gewesen sie hat nämlich immer
schon sehr routiniert Handy Nachrichten
SMS gelöscht Laptops sind verschwunden
also konnte man ihr nie was nachweisen
und jetzt sieht sie da auch beim
impfstil mit Pfizer ihrem größten Freund
dem Vorstandsvorsitzenden Albert burlaf
und Pfeife wurden Nachrichten wurden
Deals über Milliarden denn über
Nachrichten SMS und Handy Nachrichten
ausgetauscht und eingetütet parallel ist
dieser Kaiser Vertrag ähm geheim er
wurde geschwärzt und wer haben gesehen
dass die EU in diesen Verträgen sich
schützen vor Pfeifer stellt ich dachte
immer die EU ist dafür da dass sie die
Bürger schützt und dass sie sich vor die
Bürger stellt und nicht vor
Pharmakonzerne die Daten mit Impfdosen
machen parallel hat man 3 Milliarden
Impfdosen bestellt für 450 Millionen
Europäer man wusste wohl schon entweder
es wirklich beim ersten Mal bzw man muss
mehrfach impfen jetzt haben wir den
Salat und ja meine Ansicht nach ist die
EU moralisch ethisch gescheitert wenn
Sie sich jetzt nicht reformiert dann
wird sie auch noch implodieren weil die
Menschen verlieren immer mehr das
Vertrauen in die Institution EU und vor
allem auch in die nicht teilweise
demokratisch legitimierten Führer der
Institution der Europäischen Union so
das hat er
emotional diskutiert und ich glaube dass
die Kritik durchaus gerechtfertigt ist
gibt Dankeschön nächste Thema
viele Punkte die man sehr sehr kritisch
sehen muss in der EU das war jetzt ein
breites Bündel was sie da auch geschnürt
haben Herr Friedrich ich glaube ein
Punkt ist oder wäre mir sehr wichtig
dass das Thema Binnenmarkt ist aus
meiner Sicht ein extrem wichtig ist wir
wissen dass der Abbau von zölln und von
handelsbeschränkung immer dazu führt
dass
Volkswirtschaften also Bürger reicher
werden weil man weniger Geld für einen
Produkt bezahlt was man zum Beispiel
dann aus Österreich kauft oder aus der
Schweiz natürlich nicht aber aus
Frankreich beispielsweise aus Dänemark
und insofern ist der Binnenmarkt an sich
eine extrem gute Idee
alles was wir politisch in der EU noch
machen und in welcher Ausbreitung auch
das ist eine andere Frage darüber kann
man diskutieren also dass die
Wirtschaftsvereinigung dann auch noch
eine richtige politische Vereinigung
geworden ist oder ansatzweise darüber
kann man streiten was da falsch läuft
was richtig läuft ihr Thema weiß das
Thema Korruption ehrlicherweise musst du
mich da auf das verlassen was die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei uns
recherchieren wir sind noch nicht weiter
als den aktuellen Stand den wir haben
deswegen weiß ich nicht ob über Frau
kaii auch noch eine schlimme Sachen
passiert sind oder
mittlerweile werden untersucht sind also
da glaube ich um unten rechts also auf
allen Seiten im Kreis wurde glaube ich
einmal ganz genau hingeschaut wer weiß
aber auch dass man genau hinschaut genau
die EU Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt ja
auch schon gegen von der Laien und ist
in der Mitte SMS und so weiter gelöscht
worden also wie gesagt also die hat
bestimmt auch das ein oder andere den
Dreck am Stecken und wir könnten auch
über die EZB reden über die Politik und
so weiter natürlich ist die die Idee
einer Wirtschaftsunion her und gut aber
brauchen wir dann diesen aufgeblasen
Apparat in Brüssel
selbst bedient der unglaublich viel Geld
verdient der wirklich nicht effizient
ist und so weiter gibt es ja vieles
Skandale seit Jahren ich glaube wir
müssten den zusammenstutzen die müssen
wieder auch in die in die reale Welt
zurück in den brauchen eine
Amtszeitbeschränkung und die müssen auch
haftbar gemacht werden und vor allem
kann es nicht sein dass jemand wie folgt
uns davon allein nicht legitimiert wird
und einfach eingesetzt wird und da ihre
Schandtaten weiter betreibt sie das
überrascht heute dieser riesige
Korruptionsfall der ans Tageslicht haben
von evki oder sagten sie schon gedacht
mich hat es schon überrascht muss ich
jetzt sagen ich bin eigentlich also ich
bin schon bei vielen was Herr Schäfer
sagt den die grundsätzlich ist der Abbau
von Handstand eigentlich eine sinnvolle
Maßnahme und ähm es ist auch ja noch
zusätzlich so dass man wenn man mal
guckt die EU auch dazu durchaus
beigetragen hat manchmal nicht immer
aber liberale Politik zu betreiben als
das möglicherweise in einem
Nationalstaat der Fall gewesen wäre
nicht im Grunde nicht in jedem Fall das
ist richtig aber wenn wir es wirklich
schaffen durch so eine überstaatliche
Einrichtung nämlich zu diesem Abbau zu
kommen den wir sonst innerhalb des
Staates nicht hinbekommen hätten dann
wäre das grundsätzlich eine sinnvolle
Organisation aber dann muss man das
natürlich auch so hinbekommen dass die
Engländer oder die UK ausgetreten ist
ist bedauerlich denn das war eigentlich
ein liberale Kraft in der EU
insofern muss man sehen das ist dabei
sein mutiert das wird immer mehr
planwirtschaftlich sozialistisch
organisiert wir haben auch den Duktus
mit Kommissionen und so weiter Politbüro
und haben auch noch Partei Bonzen die
sich selbst bereichern fakt ist aber
auch wir haben jetzt chatkontrolle so
bekommen ne also die EU praktisch
geheime Chat Nachrichten lesen soll
zwischen den Bürgern wir sehen dass die
Landwirte das Ding des Lebens schwer
gemacht und wir sind immer mehr
Bürokratie und immer größere ein
Parteiapparate in der EU und dahin gehen
sage ich einfach müssen dem Einhalt
gebieten sonst sind wir hier die spielt
römische dekadenzen
ja gut ne nach dem Krieg zu sagen und
müssen als Europa zusammen rücken nie
wieder Krieg nach den schrecklichen
Erfahrung des Zweiten Weltkrieges
deutsch-französische Freundschaft und
europäische Wirtschaftsunion aber jetzt
sehen wir halt dass dieser dass die EU
meine Ansicht nach Europa die Idee
Europa mehr Schall als
ganz eng an dem Fall bleiben an dem
großen korruptions-skandal ich möchte
einmal versuchen ein bisschen auch in
die Psyche einzutauchen weil ich glaube
die sind Apparat EU dass er abgespeckt
werden kann da sind sie hier fast alle
am Tisch einig mich interessiert Herr
Ruprecht was haben Sie gedacht das ist
eine Frau eine sozial Demokratin die so
sagt man Bargeld säckeweise gott hat in
ihrer Wohnung was haben Sie gedacht
fühlt die sich einfach sicher ist das
quasi Routine ist es einfach nur ein
außergewöhnlicher Fall weil man sagt
aber eigentlich nie wieder passieren ist
es eine große Dummheit das ging ihm
dadurch den Kopf alles Menschen einfach
nur überraschend vor allem diese Summen
und ja das ist schon natürlich
merkwürdig aber die Tatsache dass ähm
allein dass wir da überrascht sind und
auch gar keinen Bezug zu diesem ich kann
dir den Namen ja auch gar nicht vorher
ja und ähm das ist schon deshalb
überraschend weil wir das zeigt ja dass
wir gar keine Bezug zum EU Moment haben
weil wir gucken uns vielleicht mal eine
Debatte im Bundestag an aber es gibt ja
keine regelmäßigen Debatten Fernsehen
das gibt es vielleicht ja vom vom
parlamentfernsehen der EU es ist sehr
indirekt sie haben ja gesagt von der
Leine ist nicht gewählt aber gut sie ist
immerhin eingesetzt von Regierung die
wir gewählt wurden wobei die Regierung
ja in Deutschland auch schon eingesetzt
war vom Parlament also insofern ist es
so indirekt was anderes ja das parlam
immer Regierung das ist in der Europa so
ja aber es ist einfach indirekt genug
dass man eben ja ja dass man dass man
eben gar keinen Bezug dazu hat und auch
diese man sieht dann Leute mit
Kopfhörern sitzen die in verschiedenen
Sprachen reden das wird natürlich
übersetzt aber es guckt sich doch keiner
an und deswegen hat man diesen Bezug
nicht mehr sie sind überrascht sie
wirken aber auch nicht empört spricht es
dafür dass vielleicht auch viele
Menschen sagen ja klar wundert mich
jetzt nicht Korruption im Kleinen im
großen zieht sich durch einmal durch
andere
Wohnung haben will dann muss ich den
Marker hahaha Auge zu ein bisschen was
und so geht das natürlich immer weiter
es ist was was uns einfach so
unterstellen
ja gut aber das ist natürlich immer so
eine Sache das kann man natürlich nicht
sagen da muss man erstmal die Verfahren
abwarten das ist ja jetzt erstmal wieder
Anklage oder das Gefühl bei ihnen
Abfragen ja also das ist einfach eine ja
ich kann jetzt nicht anders sagen es ist
nur Überraschung ja also das war dann
und ich glaube einfach eine gewisse
Hybrid ganz ehrlich das kann keiner weiß
aber nur komisch und man fragt sich
schon was was machen die da eigentlich
also
überrascht war ich auch aber auch ein
bisschen mehr
weil hier ja ähm eine europäische oder
die Vizepräsident des EU-Parlaments
ausgerechnet mit einem Staat gedealt hat
offenbar wenn das dann alles wirklich
sich auch so bewahrheitet der nun alles
andere als Lupen reine Demokratie ist
der ähm als Terror Finanzierer auf
dieser Welt gilt und mit dem wir einen
extrem
distanziert ist ambivalent ist
Verhältnis pflegen und sich von so einem
Staat dann schmieren zu lassen na da
muss man schon charakterlich würde ich
mal sagen sehr gefestigt sein um das so
durchzuziehen erst das Fressen dann die
Moral ne